You guys rolling? Destiny's rolling. Yep. And if you want me,
I'll do another slap of their hand. So the video and audio are synced up.
I, um, in house, in knotting them.
So I'm like everybody else locked down and I'm having a fun
time being socially distanced. Let's put it that way.
Yeah. How about you, Brittany?
I am. I'm the same. I'm locked in a room editing videos,
but that's what I normally do anyway.
Yeah. I'm getting a lot of writing done. So it's, it's not so bad. You know,
obviously a lot of people are, you know, suffering in terms of,
you know, family members, et cetera, have got to admit my family's okay.
Um, even my more elderly relatives are all care. So, you know,
it could be a lot worse. I'm getting some writing done. I'm getting some,
you know, the usual standard, my inboxes just as full,
if not more full than it used to be. So, um,
in some ways this is, you know, surreal in other way.
Whereas it's almost business as usual.
I feel a lot of scientists and mathematicians I spoke to when the lockdown
status said, this is great.
I can catch up on lots of writing and papers that I've been sitting in a drawer
for months,
but then they've been telling me I've been stuck on so many zoom calls and
meetings and other administrative things that take lots of time.
I'm getting even less work than done them before on the writing side.
That's, that's a good point. Brady. That's how it is. That's really our, I feel,
um, and it's not just, it's not just the zoom calls and that, that,
that side of things, it's the, something about the,
that the atmosphere and the environment and the Le the lack of structure
sometimes to the dare. That certainly I feel my, my productivity has gone down,
but, you know, productivity, isn't everything, as I say, you know,
healthy and well. So I've got to count blessings as it were. Um,
and the other thing, as well,
as I'm sort of glad I don't spend as much time on social media as I used to,
because I'm sure I'd get very sick of people going look at this thing. I made,
look at this thing. I cooked and look at this thing I painted on.
Look at I've solved all the world's problems in German lockdown that could get
very infuriate. And after a little while, I think.
Well,
how did the timing of the lockdown come for you in terms of what was happening
in your labs? Like where you were, you were on the brink of a great discovery.
Was it a good time for the lab to have to close down anyway, or.
No? No, it's never a good time for the lab to close down.
I was actually on research leave at the university of Alberta.
I was in Canada with Bob [inaudible] lab when,
when the whole sort of lockdown started.
And I had to cut that research,
leave short and come back instead of spending two weeks in Edmonton university
of Alberta, I had to come back a week early. Um, so,
and then the labs are completely shut down.
The pumps aren't even running on the vacuum system.
So we'll be doing a lot of backing when we go back after the lockdown.
Can you just explain.
What do you mean by you'll have to do a lot of baking. I thought,
I thought everyone was doing their baking now while they're stuck at home.
Yeah. So for us, um, to get a very, very good vacuum,
we have to heat the entire ultra high vacuum system up to 150
degrees. And we call that process baking.
And after there's going to be prolonged period,
when the systems will be not pumped throughout a static,
what we'd call a static vacuum. So they're sitting there in principle,
the vacuum should be key ish,
but there certainly need to be bags to get back to the levels of vacuum that we
really, really need to start to experiment the program again, when that happens,
I don't know, nobody knows.
Purely from a science perspective, how catastrophic is this for science?
I know a lot of industries. This is like, this is killing a lot of industries.
Is science a bit more resilient to this kind of shutdown?
This is obviously going to hold science for quite some time, you know,
experiment, experiment list. Um, we can do some work,
obviously in terms of computer simulations, we're working with machine learning,
so that can happen offline, but in terms of experiments,
no experiments are happening at the moment for experimental post-docs and for
experimental researchers. That's a, that's a real issue. And, um,
hopefully in order,
we're going to be able to get back in the lab and hopefully it will be in terms
of when university research starts up again,
I would very much hope it will be the experimentalists to we'll be getting back,
you know, allowed back on campus. Um, first,
because they are the ones that are really suffering from, you know,
not being able to have access to the science they can do. We do a lot of sales.
I see a lot of simulations. We launched machine learning,
so that can happen offline and that can happen away from the campus.
But, um,
the core of what we do is basically just entirely shut down at the moment.
Phil, a lot of industries have been able to keep working as long as they're very
careful about how they locate their people is the reason you've had to shut your
lab because of a university directive to stay off campus.
Or did you think your lab couldn't work specifically?
It's a university directive, it's a school directive. We were off campus.
I will see how that goes over the next few weeks in terms of our stairs sort of
reintroduction or a staged allowance and getting people back into the lab. Um,
in early lab,
I think we could have a mechanism whereby we'd ensure that there
were, you know,
just one person in the lab and we could have shifts and people could come in and
social distancing could still be, um, you know, going on. Um,
the problem is though, of course, is when that's not just our lab,
when it's every lab in the, in the department, on every lab in the university,
then I can understand the university's concerns.
Then it becomes a lot more difficult to manage. Could our lab continue?
Absolutely. But, um, we're not the only lab there.
I feel.
I know recently you've been having a big role at the university with admissions
of new students.
And that seems to be something that has been on your mind a bit about how this
shutdown is affecting student intake, the new students, current students.
Can you tell me about where your concerns have been and how,
how they've been resolving in your head?
I was under, as you say, I was undergraduate admissions Judah,
which means that I oversaw, um,
applications from high school students from secondary school students,
air level students, AP physics, students, et cetera, et cetera. Um,
uh, in, into our courses, uh, did that for five years. Last year,
I passed that role over to my colleague, Megan Gray,
many of you and 60 cymbal to know Mike and very well and deep sky videos would
know Megan very well. Megan and I obviously have the same concerns,
but what we are would want to just want to get the message
out there to those students who are obviously going to be worried. They haven't,
they won't be doing the exams like previous students have.
They might be a little bit worried about, um, uh, just how,
what it's going to be like the first year at university.
And of course we don't want you to panic. We don't want you to worry.
We are well aware that,
of course this is a completely different unprecedented situation,
surreal in many ways. And we of course, are going to make, um, you know,
make sure that we take a counter.
It feels like there are two issues here.
One is how you're going to decide which students get admitted if they haven't
taken the normal exams.
And the second issue is for the ones that you do take in,
what is their level of preparedness going to be in terms of, you know,
their underlying mathematical and physics ability,
because like missed the last part of their final year of scope. First of all,
in terms of how you decide who to admit,
do you even know how that's going to be done yet?
Or is that being decided by other powers? Or.
We have some idea that's obviously going to be discarded cited by,
by government overall department of education. Overall,
it will be on a levels are not going ahead in the UK.
Even GCSE exams are not going ahead.
So we,
it will have to be on the basis of predicted grades that will have to be on the
basis of, of whatever coursework is available to help teachers make decisions,
et cetera.
And we are just going to have to take those predicted grads on board and make
our decisions on the basis of those, those grades. Um,
Megan can tell you a lot more about this. I must admit I am not,
I do not envy a tall Megan's situation at the moment in terms of being an
admissions tutor during this particular period. Um, but as I said, that's,
that's largely what we're going to have to do. Um,
with regard to preparedness might the key message I want to get across is don't
panic and the best Douglas Adams Hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy where do not
panic. We are well aware that these are unprecedented circumstances.
We are well aware that students are going to be really anxious and nervous in
terms of what I haven't done, the exams.
I haven't had the same preparation as other years of how we know that.
And I'm just thought it would be a good idea to, you know,
suggest a few things just to keep the brands taken over in terms of lockdown.
So everybody doesn't go stir crazy.
Everybody doesn't start crawling the walls in terms of what physics you could
do, the type of things that we might recommend.
I hope this, I hope you're gonna recommend 60 symbols fail.
Absolutely. The first on my list is of course,
60 symbols on all those other wonderful Brady higher-end channels,
including number file, and deep sky videos and periodic videos,
even though it causes me great pain after mentioned the chemists,
but there we go. Um, yeah, so definitely there are all those wonderful,
uh, online resources. There are,
there are other videos on physics that you can find other than Brady's.
Uh, the channels, all the channels are available. Exactly.
I may. Well, if it's okay with you Brady,
I'm going to write up a short blog post on this and I'll just put a range of
different links in there. I guess the first thing to say as a sort of,
you know, keep on, keep on doing what you like about physics, you know,
keep out and, you know, watching those videos, but also reading Alec.
I can certainly recommend a whole host of different books.
There are a couple of websites I'd really like to recommend though.
First of all, there's something called, um, ICIC physics.
AIESEC has an Isaac Newton, which is a university of Cambridge based, uh,
online project funded, funded by the Ogden trust,
which has also actually funded 60 symbols in the past. And, um,
that's a really great resource for, um,
preparing both on a level, but also in a university level.
So if you want to get an idea or you want to get some, um, uh,
physics problems and thinking about just where the Le the level is going to be,
when you enter university, it's really well worth taking a look at ice expense,
it's also quite fun. The Institute of physics also has a really great site,
which is called spark.iop.org in terms of what else can you
do beyond online resources and breeding? Of course,
one thing I would suggest really heavily suggest for those of you who are into
coding cold.
And for those of you who aren't into coding star coding,
honestly, you will find it's great fun. It can be infuriating at times,
but in terms of really focusing you in terms of
learning real physics and how to code that physics and to
write a physics simulation,
that's really good preparation for any university degree. And moreover,
it's really good in terms of understanding the core,
the core physics as an undergraduate. Um, I,
and I've said this before in other videos, Brady, but it's worth repeating.
My mantra was if I can't code it,
I don't understand it because for coding a simulation,
according a piece of physics really focuses you down on what are the core
aspects here. It's a whole wide range of different projects I could suggest. Um,
and even sort of those, the, the mathematical side, where from the physics,
the things like the Mandelbrot set,
this things like the cube roots of unity fractals,
there's a whole wide range of really fun projects you could do that will keep
your math skills, um, up to, up to, to grid as well.
Just reading between the lines there.
I feel like I feel that maybe you're even suggesting sometimes when students
come through from school at the best of times,
maybe they could turn up their coding a little bit.
Yeah, absolutely. Um, so your math skills are important,
but also it's increasingly important to, to,
to start getting into coding skills.
And obviously computer five is a great place to start,
but as well as watching videos, it's like learning a musical instrument,
particularly with coding, but also particularly with physics, you have to,
you know, it's practice and it's, it's,
it's the difference between sort of passively watching a video and actively
doing something and not actively doing something will really sort of embed these
ideas. And I huge area, not just in physics,
but in all of the sciences, right across the board,
out of science and economics in practically every areas of obviously machine
learning and artificial intelligence.
And so much of physics is now that interface with,
with computer science in terms of machine learning. And that's, you know,
there are quite a few sites out, down there, some grit, um,
computer five videos on neural nets and machine learning,
and thinking about how that translates into physics is, is also, um,
something very worthwhile to do. There's a great book by the way, actually,
I've got it here. So there's this great book,
which is not so much about the details of the algorithms, et cetera, et cetera,
but it's a really good read in terms of machine learning and, um,
called reds inside the machine by a guy called Robert Smith,
not the singer in the cure, the band, the cure,
but actually a professor at UCL at university college, London. And that's,
that's well worth the rate in terms of the broader scope of how many areas
machine learning is feeding into.
Is there a particular language that one should pick up if one's going to just
start saying, okay, I'm going to learn to code w where did the,
so I thought there are a whole bunch of languages on there.
Python is a good place to start frightens, open source. It's freely available.
It's a really good place to start. Um,
but even I like I've started to get back into JavaScript quite a lot.
JavaScript is a lot of fun because you can embed simulations into a browser.
And in fact,
all you need for Java script is basically no pod on a browser.
That's really it. And then you can start coding that when it's a lot of fun,
you can tweak, you can really set up an environment.
You can have buttons and sliders and chance the parameters. And,
you know, there are things like the fusion,
there are sort of some standard standard projects,
which are still a lot of fun in terms of diffusion limited aggregation.
The icing model does, you know, even things like the simple pendulum,
if you apply force to it, you can code that. And actually that would be here,
chaotically, not randomly chaotically in the true physics sense, it's it, it's,
it's, it's a really neat manifestation of chaos, that project alone,
that piece of code alone on a simple pendulum, a driven,
simple pendulum that can keep you going for Dez. You know, and in fact,
that's, you know,
that's often one of the projects that set at undergraduate level as well.
So, um, there's a range of different different projects.
And what I'll do is I'll in the blog post I'll I'll I'll list. A few of these.
Fill the lockdown as we record now, hasn't been going for that long.
It's been a few weeks,
and I know most school students are still having interaction with their teachers
via technology and, and home learning.
I feel that how much can they be missing out on,
in their last few weeks of school? And if it's been topped up by home learning,
I mean, this can't be that big a problem.
Oh, no, it's quite it's, uh, it's, it's, uh, it's a pretty big problem. Well,
first of all, the exams not happening is, is, um, a big problem.
And so there's not that intense drive and there's not that intense motivation.
Um, at this end of the school year for GCCS and air was my daughter's actually a
GCSE. She would have been doing GCSE exams this year.
And in terms of A-level students, it's exactly the same.
There's not this same drive. They are doing homework.
The teachers are doing an incredible job in keeping them motivated, et cetera.
But with the best will in the world are not going to the classroom the day isn't
restructured. They, it's not the same environment.
It's not the same sort of overall ethos. So,
and again,
I am even finding it sometimes in terms of productivity and motivation, very,
very difficult. So, you know, students are also going to find that in, in,
under these circumstances. So, um, it is very different, I would say,
compared to.
And a lot of stuff gets crammed in. Does it in those,
in those last months and gets like solidified and you Brian, that is like,
that is a key time.
Yes, it is.
These last few months we're in the run up to exams are absolutely key.
When do, when you have to excuse my ignorance.
When would new students be starting? If everything like best case scenario,
I know there's so much doubt around everything at the moment,
but best case scenario, when will the new students come in?
It, would it be that it's, that it's the second, last week of September for us,
it varies a little bit across the UK, but for Nottingham, it will be the second,
last week in September would be the sort of induction week.
And then lectures would start last week of September,
right at the beginning of October,
whether we're going to hit that big, big uncertainty.
We'll get people on the case.
I will link to your blog and all the stuff that people can look at. Um,
one last question then, while everyone's locked down,
it's always a good chance to explore new music, any music recommendations?
Oh, why? Why, why? Whoa, thank you for that opportunity.
So myself and a couple of friends, uh,
James on paid have been this game, which is recommend a new band or a new album.
Um, uh, every, uh, every day.
I'm giving you 10 minutes. I'm giving you 10 minutes.
Oh, this does a whole host. And you miss. You're one of my favorite new bands.
There's a band called [inaudible] who managed to mix the most metal of metal
blast beats, et cetera, with folk music, basically. And, um,
pink Floyd harmonies for anybody. Who's a fan of all path.
I recommend welder on the Boston bond. Um,
in terms of old albums, if you haven't heard of Kings X,
go out and get download, beg, borrow, steal,
and out and called out of the silent planet.
And it's the third recommendation jellyfish, absolute power pop band,
nineties, or huge debt to Lennon and McCartney. Um,
but then who doesn't,
but they do the Beatles better than the Beatles. Did the Beatles.
You'll understand when you hear the albums club.
All right. Thank you for that first. Thank you for thank you,
professor Moriarty, and, uh, for your words, words of wisdom.
Thank you, Brady. Thanks a lot. Good luck.
X-ray optics.
And we need to be able to get those x-rays onto our sample to focus some time.
The synchrotron is about 10 billion times brighter than the sun.
So this is an immense engineer and challenge.